This scene here is very
high-tech. [laughs]
There are guys in the military,
certain groups around the world
that can absolutely do this.
Hi, I'm Cain Vincent Dyer.
I committed over 100 bank robberies
in a period of almost two years.
After turning myself in,
I decided to form a coaching company
that helps people transform their lives.
And today we are going to be judging
the authenticity of bank-robbery scenes
in some of our favorite movies.
He has on this helmet,
so he doesn't need a mask.
He doesn't look like he'd be
coming in to rob, necessarily.
It looks like he just kept his helmet on,
which guys do all the time.
I can really, really relate to this,
him wearing that backpack.
I would sometimes either wear a backpack
or a duffel bag strapped around the front,
and you can still have
the control of your hands.
That's the only drawback --
if you get any kind of
tracker or dye pack,
you walk off, and that dye pack explodes,
he's wearing it on his chest.
Luke: Fuck.
This is so real.
It typically happens
your first time or two.
Bank robbery is bad enough, so,
just to put that out there.
What we know from watching the movie
is he's in a really desperate situation.
Sometimes the desperation kind of
overrides the moral compass.
It's very accurate.
It takes a second for
him to pump himself up.
Luke: You! Get up!
He has tape.
He doesn't want those gloves coming off.
So obviously he's really conscious
of not leaving any type of fingerprints.
Also, it's holding his
sleeve to the jacket down,
which could be covering
up some type of tattoo.
Interesting that he
picked a bank with glass.
Because of the glass, he's
got to throw it over to them,
and, you know, they could put
any kind of device in that bag.
It almost shows more so the desperation,
that he went into this
bank that is secure,
with glass and everything like that,
but he was still so desperate
that it didn't stop him.
[motorcycle engine sputtering]
Son of a --
Him having a problem with his motorcycle
is something -- sure, it's happened.
[police sirens blaring]
[tires squealing]
They just blow through that red light
with all those cars coming.
I don't think a
intelligent police officer would do that,
just because you're putting
a lot more people at risk.
I would actually rate this
a 9.
Going into the bank,
leading up to the bank,
preparing, getting nervous
-- everything he did,
even the mistakes he made inside,
were actual mistakes that
if you haven't done it,
you would probably make.
This vault that looks like
no one could ever get in
except for probably the US military.
We have to keep in mind that, this movie,
everything about this movie
is supposed to be over the top.
Yes, they do have very
intricate lock safes
and things like that, timed lock safes,
things that are really hard to get into.
But a lot of time, during business hours,
they will keep certain safes open
just so the employees can have access.
I learned everything.
So, at every bank I went into,
I knew whether it was going to have a safe
such as the one that's in this scene
or if it was going to be, say,
regular open doors.
And if it were like this,
I would pass. [laughs]
Unless I found in one of their manuals
or knew that they would
keep this door open
between certain times.
Could I get into that?
Back then, where things
were more manual, oh, yeah.
I mean, it would've taken
a considerable amount of
time to break into that.
That's not, like, a three-
or four-minute deal.
[gunshot]
[cocks gun]
You wouldn't have a
weapon in there like that,
unless you have a security
guard that was armed.
You gotta keep in mind,
if you shoot that shotgun
and he hits that bank-robbery suspect,
those rounds are probably
exiting the perpetrator
and going straight into the bank customer
or the bank employee.
Robber: What bus driver?
[windows shatter]
That school bus doesn't
have any damage on it,
and it just crashed through
a cement and stone building.
And, if you remember,
it had to go up the steps,
because when they robbed the building
they went up the steps, and that --
like, totally Hollywood, right?
Definitely a 1. [chuckles]
The camera's already got them on video,
so why even use a mask at that point?
Either they should've
gotten out of the car,
gone straight in with the mask on,
or not used anything.
Robber: Stay down! We want to hurt no one.
The energy is so on point.
How they talk, how they
walk, how they move.
Even the customers, just
the fear that's there.
Cellophane money. The
money's still wrapped.
This is how a lot of
banks will keep the money
when it comes in.
Because they're still coming from,
you know, basically the factory.
Robber: Down! Down.
Detective: Far East National Bank, 11:30!
The silent alarm is actually going off
as they're leaving,
which is what employees
are actually trained to do.
It's less chance of the cops getting there
and them having a hostage situation.
The police are being alerted
as the bank robbers are leaving,
which is super accurate.
I would actually give it about a 7.
The energy is so accurate
for the bank robbers,
for that team. You can
feel the desperation
that it needs to get done.
Robber: Move, move, move!
All right, back it away from the counter!
They know exactly what they're doing.
You can tell by the way
they move, where they go;
they know the layout of this place.
Robber: Up against the wall!
You! Away from the computer!
Bank robberies that are done
by a lot of different gangs,
this is how they go in,
and this is how they operate.
Just with brute force and sheer fear.
Robber: When's the time lock set for?
9 o'clock.
Robber: Don't lie to us. It's 8:15.
He asked her something very
specific about the bank
which he already knew.
I would ask a bank employee a question
just because I knew the answer,
and I wanted to see
if they were gonna be
straight with me or not.
I wanted to see if they
were gonna be nervous,
how they were gonna respond
to the question I was asking.
He just wanted to see if
she was gonna cooperate.
Robber: Hold it! Silent
alarm, this address.
You pull the alarm?
No! No!
A lot of people believe
that everyone in a bank,
you know, all employees
have silent alarms.
That's not accurate.
There's very specific people
that have the silent alarms
that are allowed to push it.
Robber: Bleaching up!
Come on, let's go, we don't have time.
Bleaching is something I
haven't seen done before.
I know why he's doing it,
to get rid of all type of evidence.
You know, once you put bleach on anything,
everything just kind of dissipates.
It's just interesting to me
that they're doing that --
like, the gloves, they have on
so much that covers them up.
I would say this movie is a 10.
For the realistic way that these guys
are just that aggressive.
Unfortunately, you have
a lot of guys who go in,
and that's how they do it.
Pills & Coke: He's gonna kill us all.
Unless...
you can give me
a giant f---ing s---wad of cash.
I have a plan.
I didn't start robbing banks just
because I wanted money.
I started robbing banks
out of desperation,
in order to pay off a debt
that a very dear relative to me
had incurred to a criminal organization.
When people do a solo robbery
and they're trying not to be seen,
this is exactly how
they would approach it.
They would hand the teller a note.
They would probably
smile at people in line.
We can say he makes the
mistake of showing his face,
but most guys that go in solo like that,
they often do that, and they
hit these smaller banks,
and they just hope that the
banks don't really link up
and they won't get that much attention.
But they will go in and
show their actual faces.
You know, someone's like,
"Why is she moving that slow?"
She's probably still processing.
What they are trained
to do is try to give you
money that has some
kind of detector in it,
some kind of tracer or dye pack.
And we see the stack.
That stack looks a lot bigger
and looks like something he should take.
It could be what they
call the "bait money."
A stack that bank employees
have put to the side,
and with those are the bait
money, dye packs, tracers.
Here we see him being captured on video.
So, when I did all of my bank robberies,
it was in the end of '99, going into 2000.
And you didn't have cameras
that were as high-quality
as they have now.
So these old cameras
used to be really grainy,
so they would have a lot of them,
but it's very common to
have the cameras coming in.
There are even things along doors
that will allow a witness
to gather even how tall you are,
and you'll see it in a
lot of stores or banks.
And when someone passes it,
the employees are trained
to look where he lines up on that.
Absolutely a 10. Absolutely a 10.
But you see the man with the briefcase?
Teller: Yes.
That's my partner. He has a gun in there.
And if you don't do
exactly what I tell you
or if you give me any
kind of a problem at all,
I'm gonna look over at my partner,
and he's gonna shoot your
Mr. Gwendon between the eyes.
I have done that.
I have gone into a bank
and immediately given instructions.
I've looked back at the
door from which I came in
and told an imaginary accomplice there
to make sure everyone
keeps their head down --
not lay down or hands in the air,
but they keep their head down,
like, just their eyes
focused on the ground --
and there was never anyone there.
Take one of those big
envelopes and put as many
100s, 50s, and 20s as
you can pack into it.
He's disarming her fear.
Literally, you know?
So it's not bringing
any attention to them.
That method is a very, very common method.
I would say things like that.
Even if I yell louder at everyone else,
I would tell the person
that I was trying to get
to do whatever I'm
trying to get them to do,
I would be much more calm with them,
versus screaming at them.
The rating I'm gonna give this picture
is a 10.
You know, you would think he wouldn't
just go into a bank like that,
but people will do things like that,
especially if it's a smaller bank
and they think that the
news isn't gonna travel.
Police radio: All available units, we have
a bank 211 in progress
Nick: Shit.
at the Pico Rivera Savings in --
[police sirens blaring]
Stop!
That is super accurate,
where they're trying to back
down other law enforcement.
The FBI agent that was
assigned to my case,
Patrick Conley,
he changed how they
went after bank robbers.
And a lot of times they would
just wait for bank robbers
to get caught in the,
you know, after the fact.
And they'd get caught
doing something else,
and someone tells on someone.
We've been surveilling
these guys for weeks!
That's what surveillance is!
They commit a crime,
and then we stop them!
The police aren't working together.
In my case that happened a lot too,
because other officers weren't giving
Special Agent Patrick Conley
the information he needed,
or they just weren't
used to chasing down actual bank robbers.
Anytime he heard something come up,
he was always there.
Once that silent alarm
was hit, he'd also go.
[police sirens blaring]
[tires screeching]
I have never been in that situation,
where I have been inside
and the cops have shown up,
but I have been in the situation where,
as I'm driving away, all
the cops are coming into it.
The moment I saw all the cops,
I rolled all the windows down
and turned my music on
and started singing.
I'm gonna give it a 7,
because today, you know,
I think law enforcement
has learned a lot by not
communicating with each other.
This scene here is very
high-tech. [laughs]
This isn't a normal bank robbery, right?
There are guys in the military
and certain groups around the world
that could absolutely do this.
Now, a typical bank robbery,
you're working within a
certain construct of time.
And trying to get in a vault like that,
even if you have the
skill set to get into it,
it would probably take you
as long to get in that vault
as the sentence you would
get for getting into it.
I have gone into banks
that have safe locks in vaults
and time-lock vaults and stuff like that.
But there is a bank in Spain
that operates in this way,
where if certain parts
of it are triggered,
it will flood the actual safe
which holds all the gold.
I'll give it a 10 for entertainment,
but I'm gonna give it a 1
on the skill set
that anyone would have to go do that.
I've been waiting to go into a bank
and I've seen a pregnant lady
or an elderly person go in,
and it's made me either pause or wait,
because I didn't want to --
you know, like I said, a lot
of people, when they do this,
they're not thinking that
they're hurting the individual,
they're just taking the money.
You're putting a lot
of psychological damage
and trauma on someone.
Sometimes you don't
realize that in the moment.
Just the one, Sonny!
Sonny: Right!
This happened in 1972 in Brooklyn.
Just a horrible situation
when you have this hostage situation.
[emergency sirens wailing]
[tires screeching]
Right now he's in serious, serious denial.
I haven't been in this situation,
but I remember, even
before I turned myself in,
making the decision that I
wanted to turn myself in.
There was just so much
back-and-forth with myself.
They got me on kidnapping, armed robbery.
They're gonna bury me, man!
[audience cheering]
Attica! Attica! Attica!
Basically, he's buying time.
You're working off
survival instinct here now,
because he knows. He can't go anywhere,
but now it's just about survival.
I'm gonna give it a 10.
And were there mistakes made
in the bank? Absolutely.
Were there things that
a normal bank robber
wouldn't do in the bank? Yes.
But in this situation,
all those mistakes played
into him getting caught.
Robber: We have it, let's go!
A lot of bank robbers,
especially their first time
or something like that,
out of desperation they will just take
whatever they can put in,
and I've heard about
bank robbers going inside
and forgetting to take anything
to collect the money with, you know?
Putting everything,
trying to put everything
in a T-shirt, you know?
Robber: I got this!
He wasn't prepared for that,
which, it gave him pause,
but then he had to jump back into his --
into that zone of getting
them out of there.
So I like that they kind of did that,
where they give him this
human quality, like,
"Whoa! I didn't expect that."
'Cause he's just the driver.
Robber: Look out!
Ah! What the?!
That's a situation that
can definitely happen.
The guy who's engaging them
has a Marine Corps hat on
and a Marine Corps decal on his car.
And that was something
that was always on my mind
when going into a bank.
You know, just wondering
if there's gonna be
another guy in there like me.
He was a Marine, like myself.
It happened to me, where I had a guy
who was probably former
military or something engage me,
come at me, tell me to stop.
And I followed the command.
I know it sounds weird,
but I followed the command,
because it just wasn't worth
physically harming someone, for me.
Just that scene there, that interaction,
I would give it another 7.
We saw a lot of violence happening,
and it's easy from the outside to say,
"OK, that wouldn't happen,"
but, heck, that happens.
I've been into banks
where, during the day,
you'd see working crews there,
but I would think that
this would be something
where you'd have working
crews like that at night.
But if you had to have
them during the day,
I can see how that guy can be in there.
Robber: Easy...
Everybody get down on
the f---ing floor, now!
[patrons screaming]
I never used a team like that.
Sometimes people will get a
little violent, unfortunately.
And a lot of guys probably think
that's the way to instill fear,
to get people to do what you tell them.
But I'm kinda against that.
Once again, we're looking at Hollywood;
things would be much
more secure than that.
But a lot of old banks did
just have the glass doors.
Later on, in probably,
like, the early 2000s,
what happened is you started to see banks
incorporate this double-door mechanism.
What that was actually for
is to trap bank robbers
inside those first doors
that they went out of.
I don't know. If a bunch
of serious, trained guys
were doing something like this,
this is probably the way they would do it.
So I will rate it another 7.